[Music]
I've been on about four or five types of
sleeping pills to know them help
I'll stop bad the night bazaar I prefer
not to sleep not dream about it and
sleep and you see the picture in my head
[Music]
everybody's like oh you're going to
Cornell oh and they feel sorry for you
Delia's place on earth the Korengal
Valley we're not ready for this I'm
thinking what are we doing first friend
I lost was Restrepo where Restrepo died
we shot off flares in the middle of the
night we put up a fire base they
realized once they could not knock off
Opie Restrepo we have the upper hand
hey man I miss ya it takes a little bit
out of you every time you see one of
your boys get hurt it's really like a
big family once you guys the morning and
I want you guys to get over it and do
your jobs two months edie counting down
I just don't like the way it is I like
how it feels it I kill a bunch of bad
guys in the same instance on I'm killing
five locals I need to know better so
that I'm not killing these people
hit the bottom Arthur
as soon as I pop my head up guess huh
nobody's gonna help you you're in no
man's land
the fear is always there especially at
night when you can't see what's coming
at you are you gonna go back to the
civilian world I have no idea
I still obviously haven't figured out
how to deal with the inside the only
hope I have right now is that eventually
I'll be able to process it differently
I'm never gonna forget it I don't want
to not have that as a memory because
that was one of the moments that makes
me appreciate everything that I have
[Music]